talk to me first about I want to go way
back to back the your your roots and
your class it struck me you and Cindy
Crawford and Kathy Ireland all sort of
came up at the exact same time and kind
of created the supermodel the idea of
supermodels but you also did something
that models hadn't previously done and
that is that you really got into
business and you've done a lot of
different businesses starting with the
lingerie company and I heard a story
about how they asked you to Front for
them and you said why not I license to
you instead and that was kind of the
first turning point yes I think that you
know we grew up in the eighties and Wall
Street and we was really was really
booming not that it's not now but we
were getting advice as as as models
about how we could take more control of
our businesses and turn them into
something that truly had meaning
so I was looking at lingerie at the time
and this small company came to me and
said would you be the spokesperson for
our company and I said yes I would but I
I wanted to be not really a hired hand
but I wanted a licensing feel and you
know that was a business model that was
very successful for many years I've
actually just recently walked away from
that licensing model because I really
want to invest in businesses personally
invest in businesses that I own and you
know for example welco which is a
business that I you know I'm a
co-founder so you're now you're becoming
an actual partner in these businesses
even a founder really but
it's no coincidence that you and Sadie
and Kathy I mean you created supermodels
you also crossed over into business and
you're also very intelligent people
right you're not you're no longer just
the faces on the cover of the magazine
but actually thinking about your next
move and strategizing about life and
building an empire and yes there's the
business side which is how can I have a
more profound effect on the businesses
that I'm growing so how can I grow my
own business instead of growing other
people's businesses but also how can I
invest my time and energy into things
that are really meaningful and
purposeful for me and
that's been a big as I've matured you
know just turned 50 this year and one of
the things that's been really important
is that I actually really want to be
involved with businesses that are
impactful and that a meaningful to me I
just I wanted to put my finger on
because you know everybody's had
advisors in the past but what you've
done is more than just listen to advice
I mean you've been incredibly proactive
in this career let's talk about that
welco and the product a friend of mine
on Facebook just messaged me and said
her arms are incredible she's an alien
and you tribute a lot of the way you
look now - you have a drug-free
alcohol-free lifestyle but you're also
drinking this spirit elixir I mean is
that really what's keeps you looking so
great the super LexA is being a way of
life for me health and wellness has been
a way of life for me for a long time the
whole package it's the whole package I
think it's spiritual physical and and
and you know mental well-being but this
particular product
I am I developed with my nutritionist
for me and I wanted to find a simple
product that could nourish my cells from
a cellular level because what I realized
in time is that I can look as beautiful
as anybody else but if I don't feel good
I look more beautiful but if I don't
feel good it's actually really
meaningless to some extent and so they
show that you know 2011 women would say
what's high on their priority that would
say losing weight looking thin today
what's high on women's priority is I
want to I want to be inspired and I want
to be energized and I want to feel good
at this point in my life and so this
product for me which nourishes the cells
from a cellular level is something that
I believe so strongly and I created a
company so what I mean you have an
obvious advantage because you're working
out all the time you're eating right
you're not doing all the stuff that I do
at night which makes me look like this
but what can I gain from this super
elixir what is it is it like greens is
it like vegetables what are we the super
elixir is 45 ingredients that have been
carefully curated
from around the world in specific doses
and what it does is it nourishes your
cells right down to the mitochondria and
it alkalizes your blood which a lot of
disease and well-known wellness comes
from having an acidic body so the health
benefits are extraordinary and we've
done a lot of research and surveys and
people have have noticed not only that
they feel better their work out some
more efficient but they look better what
do you think by the way I mean you look
so good and I look at some of the other
people around you that are just looking
incredible in your in your sort of
modeling class do you think that we're
gonna see a lot more models that are our
age I mean is the demographic helping
that at all yeah I believe that the
power of women today is is between you
know 40 and 60 we have disposable income
and we're at a stage in our life where
as I said you know we we are interested
in wellness we're interested in
ourselves we invest in ourselves and we
want to be educated and we want to
invest in products that are meaningful
to us and we have disposable income so
it's a very powerful demographic of
women and I speak to those women because
they're my peers I just you know in
studying for this interview I watched a
lot of the movies you're in I know you
also hosts a couple of television shows
so I'm hoping can we see you in another
movie but I've had such an amazing you
know time throughout my career I've
experimented with lots of different
mediums and you know film television
hosting you know Saturday Night Live and
I've been just really really fortunate
my brother was on that episode of
Saturday I know you hosted with sting
all right I want to take some time we
have this segment called getting to know
you which thank god I'm gonna get yes
so number one question who is your role
model in business one of the women that
have really inspired me in my life is
Diane von Furstenberg and I just read
her recent book the woman that I want to
be the woman that I want to be and you
know I learned a lot about her her
journey and she's inspired me she's also
a close friend she's godmother to my son
as
and a great designer as well I see all
our stuff on 5f it's a great designer
but she's also she's she's had it all
and lost it all and she's focused on
family and she's you know she's
reinvented herself and she's maintained
her dignity and beauty just the way she
is all right I'm gonna skip ahead to
number four here your favorite model of
the moment it's interesting because
there are sort of our age as well
Christy Turlington and Carolyn Murphy
yes why why you choose these you don't
like any of the new the new fresh faces
I do like new hosts Britain's next
supermodel when I look at a woman I look
at her entirety so I look at Christy and
I think years ago she's a great mother
she's a wife she finished her education
at NYU and she's working for every woman
counts and she's really committed to
that plus she's beautiful I mean what's
not to like absolutely let me get one
more real quickly yes favorite band I've
been think is a great answer your answer
can we show it Fleetwood Mac there you
go what a fantastic mix I would go from
the seventies